-This is a very famous photo,
and I wanted to bring it out,
'cause I --
It just is so lovely,
you know, how much fun
you guys are having.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And what was -- You know,
what was it like working with --
Again, 'cause it was
the beginning for all of you.
What was it like working
with young Harrison Ford?
-Oh, my gosh.
Well, the thing is, he walked --
George likes to cast people that
are so close to what he wants,
he doesn't have
to really get in there
and give you
a lot of directions.
-Yeah.
-So, Harrison walks in, and he's
just too cool for school.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I just --
Instant idolization.
You know, Carrie was funny
and witty and adorable.
And we just -- we just
immediately hit it off.
It was perfect.
And Harrison had a really firm
grasp, like the overview.
I think he'd make a really good
director if he weren't so lazy.
[ Laughter ]
We'll edit that out later.
But for instance,
we were doing a scene where --
it was right after we got out
of the trash compactor.
We hadn't filmed that scene yet.
And I'm looking in continuity,
and I said, "Wait a second.
This is right after we got
out of the trash compactor.
Shouldn't my hair
be all wet and matted
with schmutz all through it?"
And he turns to me,
and he says...
[ Deep voice ] "Hey, kid,
it ain't that kind of movie."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"If people are looking at your
hair, we're all in big trouble."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Normal voice ]
And I thought, "He's so..."
[ Cheers and applause ]
"He's so right."
-He's so right.
-And next time I saw him,
he said,
[ Deep voice ]
"Hey, I don't sound
anything like that."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
But, like I say, I mean,
you'd have these moments
of self-awareness
where you're standing in
the cockpit waiting between --
'Cause once the squibs go off,
you have to stand up there.
"Kids, if you can stay up
instead of coming down,
they're gonna rewire
and do another take."
And I'd have this moment
of self-awareness.
To my right is one of
the most venerated actors
of the 20th century,
Sir Alec Guinness.
-Yeah.
-To my left is an 8-foot guy
in a dog costume,
wearing headphones.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-What's wrong with this picture?
-Well, the crazy thing now is,
obviously, you know,
it's part of, you know,
our lexicon to say things
like "lightsaber"
and "Death Star."
-Right, right, right.
-But when you read the script,
did it all seem so absurd
before we knew
what it was going to look like?
-Well, what's amazing to me
is that I was just overwhelmed.
'Cause I got the part
without having read the script.
I just did a screen test.
So I didn't know
what the style was
or whether it's a send-up
like Mel Brooks or what.
And then when I read it,
it just hit me.
I said, "This is more like
'Wizard of Oz'
than traditional
science fiction.'"
'Cause, I mean, "2001"
is a stone-cold classic.
A laugh riot it ain't.
-Right.
-And this one was so funny.
-Yeah.
-I mean,
it was so on a human level.
I mean, we risk our lives
to rescue the princess.
She takes a look
at what we came in
and said, "You came in that?"
I mean,
who says things like that?
-Yeah.
-And robots arguing
over whose fault it is.
I mean,
I knew I was the straight man.
though, "Ooh, every part
is funnier than mine."
But, you know,
if you appreciate comedy,
you realize what Bud Abbott
is doing for Lou Costello.
-Yeah.
-You know, so, you know,
when you say Threepio,
"That little friend of yours
is gonna get me
in a lot of trouble."
"Oh, he excels at that, sir."
Well, you're
lining it up for me,
then knock it out of the park.
But leave it to George Lucas
to write a script
where the robots
get better lines than me.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, in the long run, I think
it worked out for everybody.
-Oh, no,
listen, I couldn't be happier.
-It's very surreal
to have you here.
I spent a lot of time
in my youth watching you,
and it is just -- what a joy it
is to have you here right now.
-Well, in your adulthood,
you should watch "Knightfall,"
Mondays, 10:00 p.m.
on History Channel.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-I mean...
'Cause you know what happens?
You know what happens?
We go on these shows,
and I get sidetracked...
-Yeah.
-...talking about Wookiees
and laser swords,
and I come off, I go,
"Ooh! I didn't even
mention 'Knightfall.'"
-Well, there you go --
"Knightfall,"
Monday nights, History!